huge storm it has gone off war rebellion
and revolution for more than a decade
I've been outside Britain reporting on
some of the big events shaping lives and
views inside back in Britain also known
as the United Kingdom I haven't lived
here since 2005 and I want to find out
just how much has changed over the past
twelve years
[Music]
so nine I wrote activated tells us that
by going to school what about your job
it's got harder oh yeah yeah just told
me how it's got hard yeah volume I work
the amount of it the jobs don't change
it's just the amount of them since
boarding hoard of him I've been in the
job long enough for you you can you know
who's gonna be a troublemaker who's not
have you ever been attacked yeah take a
patient the hospital and he arrived to
the hospital and just completely changed
they came very aggressive puff out your
cheeks for it so Scott and Gary we go
your tongue into a tea this is a labor
of love which I get my fingers and I'm
here to find out why they do it and how
is Scott they feel they fit into Britain
today what do you think being British is
I think I feel I personally I feel
Scottish because when you hear news and
what have you and they speak about the
north they're speaking of a Manchester
you know and it's it's just good you we
go that's not North you know
Manchester's D feel forgotten yeah yeah
yeah
it's pitting the feel forgotten in
Scotland pick and because everything's a
Central Belt everything it just happens
in the central belt it's like it's a
surprise that you are you're here
because it's usually just Glasgow and
Edinburgh either they get the TV crew
sits sir
it also Glasgow I don't think I've ever
class myself as a British no thing I
ever read to be honest why I don't know
I just think that because I'm Scottish
I'm probably tell people I'm Scottish
and I don't want to be classes but
actually you like I'm ever going to hold
as a kid and in a so you're from away
from Scotland earlier England
you know no one from Scotland do you
feel connected to the English why we
don't do anything specifically with
English doesn't know and unless it's
gonna by accident
oh yeah I know we're all partners we do
we are all far but it
it may be different inside family from
other parts of the hill
and it's all abroad as I Scottish family
home my family it's much Bachmann from
generation generation above that do you
know any English people yeah yeah or any
of them you friends yeah like we Fantuz
a majority for Newcastle yeah I playing
guys as a ting over everybody and this
job initially at novice at least can be
very very short you know I mean you ever
going and every hour there facing death
near death or justice fair okay I just
took up your talk quick Mike's been
paralyzed for two years soon as you
mentioned chess being reared on your
doorstep the heart monitor is
inconclusive but he's hurting your
Michael here one of these we pop in well
if that's a far as helping the P and
make it could be your heart but he
doesn't want to go to hospital said the
crew ring doctors who check him later
yeah these guys really on the front and
an addition so under holster and making
all those tough decisions long dilemmas
all the time every day is busy and find
yourself going from job to job to job
the whole NHS looking for came in to
help GPS and without hours work and then
I would say quite easily doubled our
workload
[Music]
if we were such off for a break
so hard our period where we can only be
disturbed our certain goals as in
life-threatening cardiac arrest
that's all time again disturbance
anything else we'll just be put on the
waiting list to finish a break so what
are you having tonight
just chicken and rice you really know
how to treat yourself how would you feel
if any of your children wanted to do
your job I wouldn't want them to do that
but why is that I mean we do see the
most horrendous things I would worry
about them why over there Canoga happens
out in the States
I know what happens navarchus army wants
as we certain patients and it can be
quite difficult
take a big deep breath
something interesting we'd watch the
crew work a busy long shift you still
feel satisfied with it hmm but talking
about oh this is the best job the villa
placed I love my job
absolutely love my job yeah I wouldn't
want my kids do you know
despite the demands they're passionate
about being paramedics but being
Scottish is paramount to these men and
they feel very disconnected from the
rest of Britain